all right let's try next going two seven
one eight I don't know seven one eight
can you hear me oh hey this is Kevin
from Brooklyn okay know much I was
talking to a friend of mine the other
day with all the you know I think with
the Dems focusing on Russia and then
recently with limiting Donald Trump's
nuking capabilities I always felt that
there's so many small corrupt things
that are going under the radar the press
isn't covering like not nothing that
anyone stopped looking at it but like
I'd say like Eric Trump's a
brother-in-law and his wedding planner
like all these key positions that are
being staffed by grossly unqualified
people and I feel like no one's really
shining a light on all these
appointments that are going through
under this administration that are
undeserving people that are just Trump
cronies that are getting you know high
paying I qualified and in some cases
important jobs and like I feel like they
get no oxygen because everyone's so
focused on Wikileaks and Russian
collusion and like all the other
big-ticket things so listen I cut the
thoughts on that I do agree with you
that there is a lot of legislative meat
that is going on appointments and
decisions and all sorts of stuff that's
not getting the coverage it deserves I
don't think that it's just because of
Russia right that or WikiLeaks that
they're not it's not getting the
coverage it deserves I mean we for
example covered the story about how more
than half of Trump's appointees subject
to Senate confirmation more than half of
them had caught financial conflicts of
interest within the industries that they
were being appointed to regulate for
example we've talked about some of the
Eric Trump stuff and the charities and
all of this different stuff the issue is
there's too much to keep up with even if
you could talk about Russia never you
still couldn't keep up with it all
because the this is an unprecedented
period of insanity that is going on so I
agree with your assessment of what's
taking place I disagree that it's
because of coverage of WikiLeaks that
we're not hearing about it well I think
well I know you guys are like Ring of
Fire and Young Turks I guess I'm
more of like mainstream like old media
like CNN and MSNBC and all these other
guys yeah but it's not just I mean
listen it's it's it's Russia and
WikiLeaks and the mass shootings and the
Trump embarrassing trips abroad and the
sexual assault de Lucia it's it's a more
it's a lot of things that are going on
and we could still have a discussion
about whether those are the important
things or not but it's not just that
it's Russia and WikiLeaks that's
consuming the time all right I see your
point is yes I guess is this is
gaslighting we're living in you know we
just have a president we're just so
inundated like absolutely no to cover
all right what party Brooklyn you live
in what part of Brooklyn Oh
Bushwick Bushwick okay ever been to
David's brisket house yes I think every
yeah anyone who's been in Bushwick it's
a good good place to go I think everyone
should check it out it I mean Bushwick
is up-and-coming but that's yeah that's
one of our bright spots absolutely
David's brisket house you can take the a
train there and two recommendations here
do they would they have anything vegan
for Pat you think I even I live in
Bushwick I am a carnivore I mean I say I
think they have look I think I have um
maybe it's like a mac and cheese and
they definitely have something as a
friend of course the cheese wouldn't be
exactly vegan but yeah very good all
right I'll call up and see what they can
put together for Pat but David's brisket
house it's a great spot all right thanks
for the call really appreciate it